you guys you got to understand this this
lecture at yale you know she's fighting
very serious
mainstream oppression that's true yeah i
know you know just recently
we have this viral video this viral meme
that's been going around for some time
that's true
uh skittles i don't know if you guys
know that skittles
it's a bag of skittles it's all white
and it says skittles white pride
it's literally
but on the label at the spa store it's a
skittles white pride
it says that yes yeah they want to do
something unique for pride month
so but think think about this like okay
joking aside
joking aside skittles thought it was
appropriate to remove
all of the colored ones to replace all
of the skittles with just white ones i'm
like
that is the stupidest marketing campaign
i have
ever heard of here's the thing it is
really dumb but then again
we are talking about them every single
company does this pride month stuff and
i guess skittles is like we're gonna
shake it up and
what did they say this is the initial
shake it up like this is the only
rainbow that matters or they said
something only one rainbow matters this
month
so and i'm thinking that some promise
god made to not flood the earth again
because that's what the rainbow is for
but then it got stolen
and now it's just a cheap marketing
gimmick that every company
uses in june a lot of people can we just
skittles like they made a bag of white
skittles
they removed the colored skittles i
don't know what they were thinking this
was supposed to be
they should have just been like you know
like this is the rainbow whatever
june is the perfect month for skittles
what if they taste the rainbow
come on exactly they could be like look
we were supporting pride all along since
the brand
started existing we've always been about
the rainbow that's what we were trying
to tell you
here's what's funny right so you see how
all these brands change their twitter
accounts yes
so they put like you know rainbow levels
but then in saudi arabia they don't
skittles decided to go the complete
other direction
because like it's one thing to change
your logo it's one thing to do nothing
it's another thing to be like skittles
white pride
i see where they were what they meant
because you know when you look at white
you have white light and white pigment
white pigment is just white pigment with
no other color white light is all the
color
together so when a rainbow you mix all
the colors together you get white light
which isn't really white it's just
clear there is no you know you can't see
colors i don't think they were thinking
that no well obviously not
smart i think they were just they didn't
have a scientist on board it was just
probably some 23 year old kid who was
like sitting there like
why don't we take the rainbow out and
then make all of the skittles white
that's a really good idea so that's
inclusive co-workers are like that's
really smart man
dude you were thinking you know what
you're here
you ever hear the story of how hot
cheetos flame and hot cheetos guy made
no
i think it was like a you know the story
i was gonna say hillary clinton got to
him oh my gosh
that's awesome that's awesome no no it
was
it was in my back hot sauce so this is a
crazy story apparently it was like a
janitor right
and the the ceo or something put out a
company wide message saying we respect
all of our employees
you know to that that being said if
anybody has any ideas we're always
listening
and so this one dude who worked there he
would always take the dry cheetos with
no cheese on them
and they were extras he'd bring him home
and he would put chili powder on him and
shake him up
and it was a lot like uh like some kind
of mexican snack not necessarily a lotus
but something like that
and so then when pete when his family
started trying it they were like you
should you should tell them
and so then apparently like made a video
or something and sent it in and
everybody at the company was like what
are you doing don't
send this they don't this the ceo isn't
serious and then when they got the
message
they saw this and they realized that
people really liked the snack
they were like why don't let's let's try
making let's make it and it's it's like
the number one
or it became the number one like chip
snack that was sold in stores
so this guy got promoted became this
high level six figure dude they really
meant it's one of the coolest stories
ever yeah that is great actually this
one's gotta be the opposite
like some kid's like i got a really good
idea for for diversity and pride
get rid of all of the colored skittles
here's the question though i mean we're
making fun of them for it but has this
been negatively received
or are they doing like we did an image
that says skittles white pride
oh my god i don't think skittles is
having a good day of this
maybe you never know dude people could
buy into it they could be like this is a
great skittles that was very brave
skittles
dude i wish i was a multi yeah i wish i
was a multi-million dollar
corporation so i could like fight
oppression with like
junk mail about blm and i'm sure i'm
sure you're right that there are many
identitarians who are cheering this just
like the left cheers for all their
little corporate logos i'm sure
there are a certain sect of a certain
racial vegetarian group that's very
happy that skittles made a white pride
bag
you know this is a problem i have all
their logos are white by the way i just
looked at their twitter oh did they
change it to gray did they change them
to gray as part of the backlash
oh bro this is the worst thing ever they
also their number
their top tweet right now our most
recent tweet second most recent is
hey samsung girl they get us fellow kids
you know what i mean oh yeah you guys
see this the samsung girl that
everyone's like that's gonna end really
well
oh they made them gray they changed it
they made the skittles
fast well i think calling them colored
skittles was uh probably the mistake
in the first place i would say so yeah i
have an inappropriate joke can i say it
no
no there's like a scale is a family
friendly no
you know what it's it's my reputation on
the line what do you call colored
skittles oh no no no no no
no no delicious don't do that
delicious yes don't do this ian was
correct
this is a problem i have with calling
people oh wait do you want to do you
want to answer that joke i think it's
too risky
let's save the punchline yeah the
punchline for the after show oh wait is
there going to be i don't know
yeah oh there's no aftershow on fridays
you get it easy
let me let me derail this one real quick
i didn't even say the joke all right
do you really quick um this is a problem
i have with with calling people black
and white
is that firstly we're not and then when
people try and
market like white candy all of a sudden
it's considered racist
which is insane because there are no
white people stupidest
it's stupid yeah agreed i think it was i
don't think it was just that it was just
white candy but like white if people
were upset about this i think like the
combination of white and pride together
might have
that yeah we hear people were upset
isn't it
talk about tasting the rainbow yeah
there you go that's pretty good yeah
that's pretty good
every joke i have is rated arms come on
george so
uh ian ian is wearing the are you
wearing that this is the og
i am a gorilla let me stand up and get
this on so so we when we first made this
shirt many many of you may not be
familiar uh
the the shirt was misprinted where for
some reason teespring made the face of
the gorilla
uh darkened black but only the inside
of the face so it looked like it was
paint and the hands were white which
makes no sense because it's just a
gorilla
and it was like what a weird thing to do
to paint the face of the gorilla black
and give him white
hands terrible strange and so created
this huge controversy
and then you know teespring fixed it
apologized but i was i was like i was
i was you know pissed off a lot of
people were messaging me saying like why
is there a blackface gorilla shirt like
what is this and i'll be like dude
clearly we don't sell that that's not
it's just meant to be a meme about the
show it's
an inside joke about alex jones and then
i started getting lefties once once
once i called it out saying like this is
not our mistake
the lefties were like having a gorilla
t-shirt was racist enough
what no joke and i was like extremely
racist i know
i know that's a ridiculously racist
thing to say together
i was like dude it's it's like magilla
gorilla isn't a race thing it's a
cartoon it's like
having a shirt that's ama gorilla was a
reference to ishmael is no reference to
race
if you see that and think right man you
got problems you have
serious problems the these people say
they're racist
like robin d'angelo she writes she wrote
a book about it she said she's racist
well there you go they're not lying
that's true she walked into a party and
saw the group of black people and said
you know what i'm scared of those that's
a true story though she said that she
literally wrote that yeah
wow and she's like a foremost expert and
lecturer on critical race theory
she wrote in her book that when she goes
to parties with black people she's
uncomfortable around them and i'm like
dude ladies weird thing to say original
sin man yeah people people like
like most people don't feel that way
that's so weird
i don't know man is it is it is this is
this something i'm missing like i grew
up in chicago so
i don't have like i don't think of the
world that way and she's from the
suburbs or something
i don't know what it i but even though
you can like i mostly grew up in the
suburbs and i don't feel that way i
think it's just a weird
putting race on a pedestal uh pedestal
type thing
where you're gonna evaluate people on
that basis
for better or for worse i mean it's the
way the left has said that we should
analyze people
and she's on the left so that's how
she's going to look at everybody she's
going to put them in those categories
and if she feels uncomfortable maybe
just becomes well i must be
uncomfortable because of that person's
race because i've internalized racism or
maybe she actually just like straight up
is racist
i'll tell you this i i went to oh well
yes she obviously is of course
but you get what i mean i was in
thailand during
chinese new year in i think 2014
and i was standing in this market where
there were like thousands of people on
the streets doing their thing
i could see i could see clean all the
way like
like everybody was shorter than me so i
was standing you know with my friends
and i could i had clear field of view
all the way down the market and it's an
interesting thing you know when these
people say that like race is a social
construct and then you go to thailand
and you're like
then i go to scandinavia and i'm in a
crowd and i can't see anything at all
because everyone's seven feet tall
no i it's true though you just thought
they were because like internalized
races but
i wonder if a big component of this of
like robin deangelo's fear is that she's
never been
you know what i mean like she's never
actually interacted with these people
and so if if these people who think race
doesn't exist
ever actually traveled another country
they might be like hey
like people here are tend to be a little
shorter people here tend to be a little
taller and
hey guess what in america race is not a
you have no reason to be uncomfortable
it's like the weirdest the weirdest
thing to
be uncomfortable about in my opinion
like what about that does she
not feel comfortable with you know what
i mean it reminds me of male feminists
who want to hang out around other women
like listen i'm a pig when i'm
around you the thoughts that are in my
head let me just tell you for a half
you know what i just like i was tempted
to say you shouldn't vote when i first
walked into the room you know how
inappropriate it would be if i said this
this year
yeah i just aren't meant such pigs the
guys in the park
really is the equivalent like one of
these male feminists in the party's look
at the women and he goes uh
i just think we should repeal the night
i'm sorry i'm sorry i
and i saw women and i thought it was
wrong of me but it's what i thought
i just wanted to end women's suffrage
haven't they suffraged enough yes they
definitely have some would say so man
that's i think you're right about uh
deangelis not being familiar
rather than be like it's because of the
race i'm uncomfortable it's if you don't
if it's unfamiliar to you yeah it might
you might be uncomfortable with
something
new whether it's the height the skin
tone
the way that the posture of the body is
i don't think that's what she was saying
though yeah and that's it's weird
i i think maybe she's just like never
met a black person before she wrote
these books
that i can understand if you grow up in
a cloistered environment around one
color and size of human and then you go
to an environment where
a bunch of all humans are a different
shape and size
and color why size should you grow i
wasn't in the shire bro
probably yeah well she
i don't feel uncomfortable going to
thailand like noticing that
you know people were shorter than me
like i don't i also
it's meaningless she might have been
beat up as a kid not even as racially
just she might have been abused as a
child
so she has fear uh in general in her
life unresolved fear or something
i think it's just that she's racist but
you have close communities that have
negative views
and then you have elitist racist views
so like she probably grew up in this
hoity-toity like white community with
her mom being like
oh you know talk down to people
condescend you're so much better and
it's like the whole ideology of these
people is that they are better
like no joke it is a form of white
supremacy
not in the same sense they try to convey
right so their version of white
supremacy makes little little sense
though
prejudice plus power yes but when you
think about the core of their ideology
that they
think that white people hold special
privileged positions and have more power
and more control
and they literally tell minorities they
can't succeed i'm like bro i think
you're a white supremacist you know what
i mean well
i think for some of them what it is it's
sort of the phenomena you see with the
the kid who didn't do that poorly on a
test but they complain about how poorly
they did
like they want you to think that they
think their grade is bad
so someone will get like an a minus and
go oh i did so bad on this and then you
ask how they did and they got an a minus
so they're saying they did something bad
but it's really for the purpose of
signaling how great they are
that's kind of what i think it's not oh
i was racist but i'm aware of it
you're talking about asians right what
maybe maybe how they get a a's instead
of a pluses
and then i'm sorry it's funny to me
it's very funny to me i had a friend who
was chinese valedictorian
amazing grades perfect right cried about
getting an a minus on one of her finals
i'm like are you kidding me
i would kill to have a c on anything
that's the end of my joke but it's not a
joke that's totally true
yeah asians are smarter
i don't i think i think hold on hold on
think about this
you have you you grew up in a household
where you feel
shame for not getting a perfect score
you know
oh yeah the i mean the strictness in
reality the the strictness of these
parents as well
if you're if you're happy with getting a
c like george knight you become a
cartoonist
have you ever played those like mobile
games where you got to like it'll be
it's like a puzzle game there's one
where
there's one game i play sometimes it's
like you you press the start button and
water comes out but you have to like
draw
a ramp to like get the water to go and
you can see those ads constantly okay
now hold on hold on
so like it's it's what it's called but
like a water faucet you'll draw a
picture
you can draw lines and the water follows
the line you try to get to like ramp up
into the bucket
and you have to get three stars when i
get two stars i read to the level
i'm like you didn't beat the level
unless you get all three stars you know
oh
that's not how i work you just get one
step like i'm going through
all of them first and then i'll go back
and like and do it trying to get three
stars on the ones that i didn't bro you
should have
seen me beat sonic the hedgehog earlier
i didn't care how many
rings i got i was like to the end of the
level yeah see i have to get literally
every ring in the game otherwise i start
the whole thing
no no not that much you unplug the
arcade machine but it's like if you
don't if
like i've got one game where you have
like a little guy needs a backflip and
you tap the screen and he jumps and you
tap it again and he tucks and then you
let go and then he lands the back flip
yeah and i'm like i gotta get
in the ring perfect max score every time
and if i don't i just keep restarting
until i do it
it's frustrating like i feel like if i
don't get a perfect score i didn't beat
the level
yeah you know yeah i'm not gonna cry
about it do you think that's a nature
nurture thing i've always
man this is interesting um i think it's
probably a little bit of both yeah but i
definitely grew up in a household where
when i like before i even started
kindergarten my mom was teaching me math
and reading yeah that's good so i
started kindergarten i knew
multiplication and division and long
division all stuff
like all the other kids were like two
plus two is four and i was like
27 times 493 and i could do the math you
know yeah
so maybe it's my cultural thing does
your parents expect like greatness out
of you
and and punish or not punish you but
like be like it wasn't good enough if
you didn't get the perfect score or were
they just kind of like
handled the video game they made them
replay video game levels if you didn't
beat it completely
no but there was this game we used to
play in first grade called around the
world i love that game yeah
you know what it is like so you stand up
at your desk and then you stand behind
the person with your hands on their
shoulder and then the teacher would do a
flash card
me and my brother would never lose so
the teacher would eventually ask us to
stop playing
yeah because like first grade and show
the card like boom i know the answer
seven
fourteen three isn't that ridiculous
what an example of how
public schools busted the smart kids
this is catholic school
even catholic schools busted the kids
that are so good can't
can't participate because they ruin it
for everyone else what are they supposed
to do i don't know i have this again
they're like tim we get it you know your
math have a nice day like you won here's
your prize now
go go play with your prize like the
other kids got to learn math too
so what is it is it it's interesting
right so uh i'm literally asian and i'm
good at math
i've had this theory for a long time
because you said that tim
i'm allowed to say it well i grew up
around a lot of asian kids uh just
in the area that i lived in so i would
go to their houses and
see how their parents interacted with
them a lot and i had this theory of like
from certain countries when they were
immigrant parents
they understood how hard it was to climb
the social ladder let's say
a lot of immigrants start with very
little let's say so their parents know
like
you have to study ultra hard i'm gonna
push my kids super duper hard because
we're not gonna
we're gonna like leapfrog up you're not
just gonna be a normal person i'm gonna
like
train my kid to be like for instance i
grew up i won't say the towns but
i used to tutor kids after school and
stuff with art and whatnot
a lot of asian parents would not let
their kids come home after school
you have piano practice art practice
whatever all kinds of different
practices they would push their kids
you weren't even allowed to come home
you had to go to the library after
school
like i just i noticed the way that they
raised their kids a lot
and the kids resented at first
but then they kicked so much butt as
they get older i do remember you know
when i was a kid like
my mom like drew a picture it said if at
first you don't succeed try try again
and like those message
that messaging i also remember being
like 13 and trying to learn how to kick
flip
and by choice i stood outside my house
for like eight hours every day
kickflip heelflip like skateboard tricks
right so heelflip is when you
pop the board and then with your heel
you kick it and it flips
one day i could just do it it was like
it came naturally to me everybody kind
of has the tricks that just natural at
but kickflip like one of the most basic
tricks everybody can do i
struggled with and no one made me do it
there was no prize there was no
no parent sitting there saying you have
to land it it was just like one day i
went outside my board for eight hours
just trying and i was frustrated i was
angry i never get it made no sense to me
and i remember the first day i finally
landed it and i landed at crooked and i
was like yeah
i did it no one told me to do it there
was no
i wasn't forced to i got no prize for it
other than my own so i wonder
you know i think i think everything's a
little bit of nature and nurture and for
me especially
there was i don't i don't think there
was something in my life that
i can't recall other than maybe just
being around hard-working parents
that maybe i don't realize how much that
really buff on me but there's a lot
about
me obviously where i'm just like i have
to do it it has to be perfect yeah it's
similar with me and drawing and stuff
and i'm sure sheamus you can agree
there's a certain satisfaction to
setting a goal for yourself
oh yeah and then realizing wait i did
that but nobody
taught me how to do it there's just some
miracle of
uh this feeling of hard work
equals results and if i keep doing this
one thing over and over like i'm a huge
fan of the ten thousand hour rule let's
say yeah if anyone asks me how do i get
good at drawing it's like well have you
drawn ten thousand hours
get started or yeah continue down the
road um but that lesson
i don't think it's necessarily racial in
the sense of like it can be passed from
parents
to kids or something like that you're i
don't think so maybe some people are
born with it some aren't but
i don't like that um there's a cultural
excuse
of where i'm born in a position where
uh let's say some people are more ahead
of me than i am
i don't like the excuse of uh well i'm
just not gonna try because i
was given a bad hand at birth or uh
that's that's the narrative of the left
man but it's not your fault don't try
but it's such a lie it's such a you're
you're playing yourself if you think
that you
are not in control of your future if you
keep
trying to do something just one thing
pick one thing you
love yeah just keep doing it and
eventually
like i didn't make my br my big break or
whatever in cartooning until two years
ago
i had been drawing i made my debut or
whatever back in 2006.
exactly i couldn't get a job in comics
until two years ago
it takes a lot a lot of people don't
know this but before sheamus started
freedom tunes it was comey tunes it was
coming too
i was actually far left activist and
then i was like all right i'm gonna try
to be a little bit more moderate so i
made biden tunes and i've said this
before which is huge which is good
which is better which was good but then
at one point i was like you know what
i've got an idea
let's try freedom tunes and i i'm here
today
but um i mean i agree with you right off
you [ __ ] great
yeah it's funny because no it takes a
really long time to become successful in
anything
and for me it wasn't just drawing i mean
i i'm pretty
mediocre just like the raw art of
drawing something photorealistic i'm
much more into cartoony i used to be
a lot better at drawing in college when
i was doing it consistently but the
point is for me
the payoff was trying to see how quickly
i could get something done
that looked decent and that skill set
obviously turned out to be out for me
because
uh because we're uploading stuff all the
time and that's a huge strategy for our
growth but
yeah i hear that in on the other hand
there's very much a nurture component to
it how much were you pushed as a kid to
not give up
how many virtues reinstilled with but
there is a nature part of it which is
how interested are you in the thing to
begin with
exactly i think parents can can give
kids drive
i think absolutely if parents just make
their kids stick to something it helps
and whatever gets your butt in that seat
for ten thousand hours honestly
that that's a sorry oh i was told that i
could do it which is why i believed i
could otherwise i never would have tried
okay
my parents never and like they never
pushed me to do art or
actually like it's a funny thing i was
told your parents never pushed you to do
nobody pushed me i'm giving you hard
times i think most people's parents are
like please don't do art do anything
besides art my whole life it's been that
story no for real like i was i tried to
go to art school they're like why don't
you go to like real school
exactly can you get a real degree and
then just do art on the side but there
was just something in me that
said i have to do this and this this is
the only thing i can do
i'm not good at anything else this is
one of the i think one of the biggest
problems with
modern society especially for young
people is the obsession with college
so after occupy wall street and i'm
featured in i get i get all this press
on featured in magazines
i still had family being like will you
go to college now yeah and i was like
no no no no i'm going to college right
now i'm on my way 25. okay
i'm going to college right now i'm on my
way to give a guest lecture to the phd
course on journalism
yeah i was like what do you what do you
think i would learn when i'm the one
being brought in to like teach these
people things they don't know
stephen colbert got an honorary degree
after he was just stephen colbert the
goofball on tv
they were like we love him so much we're
going to give him a college degree for
that i know art school dropouts who
they dropped out of art school and then
later they got a degree honorary degree
something like that and they ended up
teaching at that school
that's a weird thing you should really
only go to it for the skills you're
going to pick up the degree probably
that and networking yeah networking is
the the biggest advantage too
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you